God was a number being the most
forgiving game but there's nothing quite
like shanking your ball into the drink
or pond that's where this guy comes in
here at TPC Sawgrass hundreds of golfers
lose their balls to the infamous par-3
17th hole but one golfers misery is
another man's gold this is gordon davis
my name is Gordon Davis and I'm a
professional golf ball diver he makes a
living diving for golf balls all over
Florida other dollars for golf balls
approximately 50 years there are a lot
of boats to be found on average I've
when I'm diving
I'll pick up three to four thousand
three or four thousand three or four
thousand whoa so how do you find these
golf balls it's mostly you know just
feel picking them up out of the mud and
some places much too deep that you can't
do nothing with it you know and it's
that much that makes it impossible to
see will anything most courses they very
few that if it has clear water most of
them poor visibility because of the
algae and all that so what happens next
after I pull the balls out they go
through pick out some of them and they
take them from there they being someone
who wants to repurpose these balls these
balls are authentic these authentic
balls are diced up placed in all sorts
of usable keepsakes like cufflinks
watches and bottle of this and according
he knows what it takes to be a
professional golf ball diver well I tell
people you got to be a kind of a special
cat a bear guy for divers somebody with
grit and it wants to be a independent
person especially any other business
someone has to do it everybody has a
different job and this is happen to be
mine
seeing as you're kind of a special cat
any advice for golfers trying to keep
their balls dry yeah take up another
sports
[Music]
all in one